hey everyone and welcome back to the
countdown to the 2020 emmys on et live
i'm liana gullera and i'm thrilled right
now to be joined by et's katie krauss
hey katie
hey leanne oh my goodness katie i've
enlisted your help today because you
love two things
brad pitt and jennifer aniston and they
are both
nominated this year and and also who
doesn't love
them who doesn't love them and who
didn't love
when we saw those interactions between
them we had some arm grazes we had
longing looks
and even though we're gonna be virtual
this year do you think we can expect
some sort of brad and jen sparkle i mean
i hope so
they know what the people want and over
the years i mean they've definitely
given us
a lot of award show red carpet moments
together and we wanted to show you guys
some of our favorites
jennifer aniston and brad pitt continue
to be the queen
and king of award show season i'm very
happy
this year the two hollywood a-listers
both nab themselves an emmy nomination
i mean it's nice for me brad for his
three-minute guest appearance as dr
anthony fauci on saturday night live
and when i hear things like the virus
can be cured if everyone takes the tide
pod challenge
i'll be there to say please don't and
jen for her lead role as alex levy on
the morning show
it was flat do not overreact just go
with it
you'll get used to this but these two
are no strangers to the emmys
i just went to your building and you
weren't there and then this guy with a
big hammer said that you might be here
and you are you are
can i get you some coffee decaf when
friends premiered back in 1994
jen and her castmates quickly earned
emmy recognition
first year to even be nominated is so
unbelievable
that you know but what more can you ask
for
we were just happy to be there so we
didn't win we didn't win
oh no we didn't win jump to 2002 jen and
brad who were married at the time were
each other's dates to the big awards
show and it was that night when jen took
home her first individual emmy for best
actress in a comedy series
it really does feel good i have to say
that same year brad was nominated for
outstanding guest actor for his
appearance on friends
remember the one with the rumor rachel
and green
oh oh that's right are you are you gonna
be okay well
i'll be fine just god i hate it ross
either the actor did not take home the
trophy that night but he was by gen's
side to celebrate her win
what did brad say to you after you won
we were both just going oh my god
it's it's surreal he said he was nervous
for me
i was nervous for me brad and jen
divorced in 2005 but were all still
obsessed with their run-ins during award
season earlier this year
what do you make of all the
ridiculousness about you and
brad reuniting on all these carpets all
season long it's hysterical but what
else are they going to talk about
the favorite former couple both won big
in their categories at the 2020 sag
awards
it was a lovely welcome back it's been a
long time and that's why i
met when i said you know i know when
this when i get invited into this room
it's really special
because it's my it's my peers it was
following brad's win that their iconic
reunion happened
and after their bump in cameras caught
brad's reaction backstage to jen's
winning moment
what do you make of our reaction to the
big reunion backstage last week at this
edge i don't know i'm blissfully naive
and i'm going to stay that way
i'll run into jen she's a good friend